[Music]
ryan is on the line in jupiter florida
ryan welcome to the ramsay show
thank you guys nice to talk to you today
how you guys doing you as well how can
we help we're good man
well this this may sound like a silly
question but my wife and i are both
retired we're totally debt free cars
house everything
and but we have this habit
of three or four times a week we go to
our favorite coffee shop which is as
stores worldwide
and i drive up we order our coffee i go
to the drive up window they scan my app
and they give them my coffee and after
so many cups of coffee i get a free cup
of coffee
am i doing this ride or should i
take cash or
well there's a simple framework for this
and i'm gonna just go ahead and guess
you're talking about starbucks
well yeah okay
okay they have like your most capable
in florida so that's why i guess we're
on to you ryan i i do the same thing and
here's the here's the easiest way to
look at it is it in the budget do we
have a coffee budget because we love
coffee and we're just going to say we're
going to go three to four times a week
and we planned for it or are we letting
the rewards drive our spending decisions
that's that's the difference we have to
parse out
because truthfully that free cup of
coffee it's what two bucks i mean i
don't know what you're ordering a fancy
latte
no just a cup of coffee not a boy boy
ryan
i had a habit of that a few years back
in the old ramsay building i would stop
every day my way to work and it was
budgeted for and i would get my grande
black coffee for two dollars and 61
cents and you better believe that was in
the budget and so as long as it's
planned for you don't have to feel
guilty about it and the rewards you're
not going into debt for this coffee so
there's no guilt around the reward
system but don't let that drive you to
go well i'm going to spend 20 bucks at
starbucks so i can get a two dollar cup
of coffee you know what i mean
my other my other side of the question
is
you know i can download money into the
app
should i use my credit card or should i
use hold on hold on ryan ryan you're
using a credit
stupid question you want card cat out of
the bag your debit card yes just load it
up man i mean it just works the same
yeah what i do is i don't overthink it i
keep enough on there and then if i don't
have enough money for my next purchase i
reload it with another 10 bucks but i'm
not going to pre-load it with 150
dollars either you know yeah but if you
want to pre-load it with whatever's in
your budget you save 50 bucks in the
budget this month for for starbucks load
it up man load it up with 50 bucks and
if you run out sorry time to make some
coffee at home in fact i could see that
being a great way to control over
spending there right is i'm gonna put my
coffee budget on this prepaid app and
when it's gone it's gone right yeah i
like that i'm with that that's a great
question though because there is there's
still the mental game and rewards and
the gamification this can drive us to
make some poor financial decisions well
i could see somebody who said okay i'm
going to get rid of my credit card with
points because i don't want to live the
points game and then go oh but i'm
getting coffee points over here is that
okay and one of those you mentioned it
one of these is going into debt with the
promise i'll pay you back in 28 days
this one is dude this is your money and
if you just keep being a repeat customer
i want to throw you a little cup of
coffee every once in a while i'm not
even really paying attention to if my
rewards are at the point where i get a
free drink once in a while go oh okay
you know my wife's getting a fancy drink
let's go ahead and use the reward right
that's another thing take advantage of
that you know if i get the free reward
it's good for anything at starbucks any
so i make the craziest drink possible
just to make the baristas mad i'm like
i'll do eight shots i'll take every pump
of whatever you got give me the fanciest
most expensive oat milk you have back
there i'm like cool that'll be nine
dollars i'm like sweet i'm using my
reward
zero i don't ever make baristas mad
because they control your life that is
true that is very true i'm not that i'm
not that treat your baristas but
starbucks has a range you can either get
a two dollar drink or a nine dollar
drink you get to make the choice
i tend to go to the cheap side john you
know me that's me too you know me black
coffee will do i'm there for the cafe i
just get water from the hose out back
now ken coleman he likes a white
chocolate mocha i'll have you know
america he's a fancy man
i love it good conversation not one that
anyone needs to have but we had it
anyways